yeah welcome to this video playing
against and FM here from the US Ser gone
dumb playing a Queens gambit declined I
need some safe and secure position
played very badly recent games
so we got the last guy variation of the
Queens gambit declined 95 film so quite
uncommon move
yeah well I can just go 97 for c5 just
loses some time so it's attacking the
beep on
yeah it's not so clear what what exactly
White's plan is in this position maybe
he's some going form e for
yeah it seems that this is the case
yeah I have some some counter play
though what should I play 27 35
something like that I need to cover d 5
mm or rock dat even I'd like to yeah
probably upgrade also giving some room
for the king
ok
I take on dat threatens to take on d5
slightly annoying maybe am I really
should go here yeah get out of this out
of the you foul
yeah this is of course some very double
edge to the smooth it might be great
with effort to come but it also gives me
am the C file and I Scott Bishop a six
it's a possibility Roxy three is got
this Bishop age seven check
should I play move like g6 don't know
yellow this at least threatens Roxy
three the Queen on g5 makes sure he
cannot oppose on the C file
okay yeah Roxy to win problem don't want
to go back
I have rook d7c seven maybe yes but
Queen d2 I thought would be would be a
good move attacking f2 and a to locally
to does Roxy one and there's Luke c3 in
the mix
but could not sure what you should even
move now it's not easy Brooke a tues
also or maybe in some cases Queen a five
well now I can even take g4 maybe I
should play it should take d 4 that's
probably not bad you keeping pressure on
f2 and the central porn is Sir is quite
something
this also gives me a good spot on c-54
for the rook it's at some point if it is
attacked maybe rock d7c seven am I
should I should get this other look on
the C file h3 was to prevent Quincy form
looks good
yeah Queen d8 but is it such a problem
don't think so i can just go to age 7
twin c5 to e7 that's my idea oh stop
does he have Bishop g6 for the shame
mmm Bishop g6
Kira this wasn't necessary
I want to control the third-ranked yes
but it's not threatening that much Queen
I want to have Queen g7
the rook takes h3 now using the Queen on
the on g7
yeah I'm not threatening something but
he doesn't really have a constructive
move the problem I threatened not to
take basically Queen g5 sub thread but
he doesn't really have a move still I
wonder okay I can just take it and play
Queen g5 intending rooks you want yeah
yeah I overlooked this Bishop g6 stuff
of course this is sam with g6 always
slight liability but i think how i
should have enough play with with the C
file and this is now certainly a very
good but I forgot about this possibility
with Bishop d3 black star seems to seems
to control what's happening how rocket
III now is very good for white computer
gives this mmm yeah I have Queen e7 here
instead of Queen afraid this is much
better yeah ahead was it was rather
shaky for black no it's fine again yeah
it's difficult with so little time to
play yeah thanks for watching